dans l'île la moindre vieilles pierres
évoquent la période de l'esclavagé et le
coeur des hommes comme la pierre garde
le souvenir des drames passés le docteur
la guerre étudie ces traces laissées par
l'histoire dans l'inconscient pour la
chercheuse petits et grands ont une
psychologie fortement marqué par
l'histoire
même s'ils ne l'ont pas beaucoup étudié
les premiers traits communs très la peur
du manque et le sentiment d'infériorité
pendant longtemps d'un fait croire aux
eaux noires qu'il n'avait pas de
compétence que c'est que c'est un meuble
par exemple donc c'est vrai que pour
pouvoir s'affirmer et pouvoir mettre en
valeur toutes les compétences et les
belles choses que nous savons faire
c'est un peu un peu compliqué avec le
manque de confiance en soi
on a du mal à s'affirmer et donc ça
revient en fait à la question de
l'identité du peuple
comment je fais pour faire peuple en
fait c'est un peu la question
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
réaction à cette faible estime de soi
passivité et l'effacement chez certains
colère et violentes chez d'autres qui se
retrouveraient de façon cyclique dans
des manifestations sociétale
effectivement on va voir dans les
réactions dans certaines réactions et
dans certaines manifestations ce désir
de s'affirmer mais sauf que ce désir va
être parfois en fait cette volonté va
être parfois imposée et on voit qu'il ya
une fracture justement dans la
population puisque certains
veulent affirmer quelque chose d'autre
ne se reconnaissent pas forcément et ses
skis et c'est ce qui crée ce désordre
aujourd'hui à la martinique pour la
chercheuse
la plus grande fêlures post-esclavagiste
serait ce trouble identitaire
cette grande difficulté à s'unir malgré
tout la culture que les martiniquais ont
bien en commun